[Music]
no idea
in this film we wanted to kind of strip
it back and wanted have more fun with it
you know I'm tyka had the exact same
idea and we were both saying install
Ragnarok it's trying to have more
attitude ragnaroks sort of a new cycle
from the light of the world in all the
realms of the universe it's the
destruction of the old' and the rebirth
of the new that's really exciting to me
surprise this would be such fun it the
way that I've approached this is to
rebuild it in a new way
look great dude totally I think it's
just perfect mix for where the character
and story need to go you know different
costumes different weapons different
cast or characters to work or give you a
different energy
Thor is in a crisis he never went back
to Asgard to claim the throne he wanted
adventure when we pick him up he's at
the end of this search for himself once
we survive this trip I'd say the odds
are about
a million fun
you know I want this to take people on a
ride and and pinch it some comedy into
it an adventure that keeps people
laughing along the way but also has
inspector call them the stuff that it
gets people excited he's a fighter
[Music]
you
[Music]